at some point in that program somebody
or something probably swings from it
yeah yeah yeah like something like that
i can't keep up there's so many cirque
shows i've never seen them all right
they're so they're always good and they
don't ever disappoint
this is vegas
we got the concerts we got everything
we've got great chamber of commerce
you know what i noticed with the the
wind today mellowing out yeah i've been
i got an umbrella in the backyard yeah i
have picked that thing up oh so many
times three days a week for two months
yeah that's that's gonna be an issue
this weekend to go out there bring it in
bring it in okay i'm gonna bring it
maybe i need to buy a higher quality
umbrella
i don't think that's gonna help with
these woods we got this weekend for
mom's day so yeah uh brian but a good
point and we're gonna talk about this
all week as we head into mom's day
weekend that's one of those times where
you got to bring in the patio furniture
anchor down the trampoline for sure not
an issue right now though i'm liking it
outside at this hour mainly clear skies
temperatures are comfortable 81 degrees
not bad at all that was below normal 62
for the low record on this date again
was a hot day 108 degrees that was back
in 1947. here in neighborhoods right now
not bad at all 81 centennial hill spring
valley at 80 even we're at 82 north las
vegas 83 whitney ranch in green valley
mountains edge 78 82 henderson and
southern highlands 81 just a nice night
to go out for a little walk walking the
dog 83 in prep for you 84 way up there
in mesquite now some lapla right now
clear skies that low continues to move
off towards the east and as it does the
winds start to calm down even more
that's what we saw
this afternoon we've got this ridge
that's building up over us and what
that's going to do is this the next
three days are going to be very warm
we'll go from low 80s today to 94
tomorrow 95 friday 93 saturday this was
the hottest tip so far on march 26th and
look at this we're going to be warmer
than that for these next few days
nowhere near those records though
thankfully those are in the triple digit
territory but we do expect winds to pick
up a little tomorrow not in the morning
this will be mainly later on a day where
it could get a little breezy in the
afternoon this might actually help with
that heat give us a little bit of cool
down with uh some of that heat that
we're going to see for tomorrow so
here's your forecast 64 overnight a nice
clear night tonight and light wind
tomorrow 94 like we talked about breezy
later very warm remember we should be at
84 this time of the year so we'll be 10
above normal a lot of your neighborhoods
here pick your neighborhoods look at
this mid 90s tomorrow 90 for someone
though 91 anthem warmest spots are going
to be green valley and of course sunrise
manner out on the east side triple digit
heat though for you in life with the
century mark 105 for death valley
tomorrow no thank you eight day forecast
shows the heat cooling down for mom's
day gusty winds for mom's day remember
after making plans seventies next week's
gonna feel more like march that mother's
day logo is big of course because why we
love mom
it's mom's day we don't want anybody to
forget the gift giving that is
absolutely why i'm going to make it
bigger right today's hump day so you
have still tomorrow and then friday
yesterday saturday countdown
all right chris is here now with as we
know the season for the